this is Sadie's song I'm not gonna lie
while watching this episode I think to
myself ma I one thing I say about this
one it's a pretty pretty cut-and-dry
episode it doesn't mean there's nothing
to it but it is one that you kind of
know where it's gonna go it's kind of
like the nightmare hospital you know
where it's gonna go and it's like okay
fine but it doesn't feel like the last
episode that I did on here where it's
like oh wow that's like a new way of
showing this name it was pretty standard
but it's fine
Sadie is um singing in inter store and
Steven says oh you should saying there's
this beach-a-palooza thing going on so
she agrees but then her mother is kind
of a sports mom and just pushes her to
the ultimate extreme and she feels too
pressured and finally when the big night
comes they got her all dressed up and
sparkling and everything and they you're
announcing her as this big special guest
and this mystery guests and she feels
too pressured cracks pretty much and
Steven decides to go on instead of her
and gets a big laugh and everybody
cheers and stuff and in the end she
talks to her mom things seem to be okay
and then she's also just singing a
little song in the back of her store um
a little ukulele that Stephens playing
um it's I wasn't the thing I like the
most about I think I like the ending the
most I like that she just wanted to sing
you know a little bit got caught up and
then in the end it's just her kind of
singing a little bit in the story you
know just a little guitar um I think
that is something that's always kind of
important you kind of got to say would
you if you're gonna pursue something
like you know that's a hard thing to
pursue and you want to pursue it really
really hard and then I'm really big
would you still do it even if you were
just alone wait would you do it as a
hobby
um because there are a lot of people
that I've seen that think they want to
do something alike kind of what we do or
yeah various types of entertainment and
stuff and you can tell they're like that
this isn't what I thought it was going
to be
this is you know I'm sick of this
already but I can't get out you know or
some do some don't whether I mean
there's there's so many different
amounts of people on so many different
ways people are going to accept or not
accept certain things that come along in
their life and yeah I think that is
that's an important lesson to learn is
that you know would you be okay doing
this for you know millions of people or
to people and which would be okay with
either or neither you know there's
people that can't perform in front of
you know whatever five people you know
let alone millions of people uh and
there's people that need millions of
people always looking at them and stuff
so it's it's interesting like you know
it's I think it's very much find your
voice and find your audience even if
it's a couple people even if it's your
parents or your brother your sister or
something like that so I think that is a
good lesson I think that last image is
kind of the the strength of it all I
think that's a very nice quiet image to
end on uh so many times we see a lot of
these like biographies and stuff ending
with you know someone in front of a
crowd and everybody cheering and stuff
and those are great but I always like
the one that end with like you know the
person just alone somewhere doing
something very common very normal maybe
just hang with a friend or something you
know or just drawing or singing or
something you know so I like that image
as well you know it's something that
shows there still a connection that was
always there to something that you
pursue so hard a lot of times the reason
people do make it in you know whatever
singing or whatever is because you know
they pursue what they did love and that
is very much what they love and they put
up with so much crap because there is
that love um so I I like that but
there's also people who don't need to
pursue it and are totally fine you know
just keeping a small keeping it a hobby
keeping it just something that they love
it doesn't have to be something that the
world loves it can be just something
they love um so I like that I thought
that's all kind of work came together
uh trying to think not too much I was
like nothing really connected to the
continuing story or anything uh it
wasn't especially funny uh I mean you
know there's a few labs here there but
nothing else like uh like any of the
other episodes um and uh yeah there's
the one thing that I always kind of like
it makes me laugh but I always kind of
squint my eyes a little bit like really
you know is when you see the parent of
somebody and they just look like the kid
they like a grownup version of the kid
colleague Milhouse's parents like I get
it and it's funny but the fact that
every single one of them look exactly
the same
just always bothers me a little bit um
maybe it's because they actually form
unique personalities later like
Milhouse's family actually have very
distinct personalities now the mother
and the father they're they're very
different people and it you see how
Milhouse is brought from that you know
cuz just of how they are but you know
that what they first designed them
they're just like you know oh well let's
just well I think they drew the mother
first end episode and then they needed
the father for something that's just
like what should the father look like
well the model looks like just like
Milhouse what if he looked exactly like
male house you know exact same thing so
I don't know it's I can't say it's like
a cheap shot or a cheat or anything like
that because it is funny it's cute but
there's something about when they form
such distinct personalities and a mother
clearly had a distinct personality that
I'm always thinking you know it doesn't
have to look that much like like the kid
you know then not like a carbon copy now
I could clone um you know Stephens mom
Rose I mean you can tell that Stephens
mom yes we're the same no as a kind of
round face and stuff but still looks
like her own unique character so I like
when there's little clues and hints but
not we're just gonna draw the exact same
character so I don't know
that's a real nitpick I'm just like I
said it was more trying to find stuff to
talk about for this episode uh and yeah
I think that is
all I got uh these will be the last of
me alone at least hopefully by the time
by the time these roll around rob will
be better so yeah that's about it and I
shall talk to you later
take care